this school in tripoli will soon become
a polling station
wednesday is a deadline for registered
voters to pick up their voter cards
ahead of the first round of presidential
elections scheduled for december 24th
it will be the first presidential
election in libya's history and more
than two million people have received
their voter cards so far
but the vote has been marred by
controversy some say holding
presidential elections without a
constitution will only plunge the
country into further violence
this crowd has gathered in front of the
election commission headquarters calling
for the vote to be postponed until a
constitutional referendum takes place
without a constitutional foundation
in any nation in the world you cannot
conduct a proper and neutral and just
election this is abcd it is the very
beginning lesson in democracy you have
to have a constitution which regulates
respect identify the identity of the
country for this election this election
proposed election it is very dangerous
for democracy very dangerous for a civil
state and we think personally speaking
that this election is not going to end
in a peaceful manner
libya has been engulfed in violence and
political division since the revolution
that toppled walmart gaddafi in 2011.
with warlord khalifa hafter controlling
the oil-rich region of eastern libya
and the internationally recognized
government of unity in the west led by
prime minister abdul hamid daba both men
are among scores of candidates running
in the elections
across libya people have mixed feelings
in my opinion presidential elections
right now should not take place you
shouldn't have presidential elections
before the parliamentary elections and
there should be a constitution
i'm in favor of these elections at least
the situation will get better we want
our country to move forward in my
opinion it's the only way to end the
violence
just three weeks ahead of the vote
libyans are still deeply divided there's
international pressure for the elections
to move ahead as scheduled but without a
constitution in place many here feel
presidential elections will only prolong
the conflict mala trainer al jazeera
tripoli